how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel yesterday we finally got the
title and a tiny tiny little teaser from
Sony for venom to officially titled let
there be carnage for those of you
wondering yes there is going to be
another teaser a better teaser where
they actually show footage but
unfortunately since the movie has been
pushed back so far that probably won't
come until at least another few months
but nonetheless Sony gave us something
and it seems like Tom Hardy is giving us
something as well for the past week and
a half
Tom Hardy has been teasing spider-man on
his Instagram he's been posting photos
and then deleting them he's known to do
this and this time we have proof
many people have expected that we could
see a cameo from spider-man in venom -
let there be carnage and Tom Hardy may
be teasing that on his Instagram so
let's jump right in real quick don't
forget tonight I'm doing a video
announcing the giveaway winner for five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
so look out for that so about a week ago
before we got the official venom to
title and teaser Tom Hardy posted a
photo on his Instagram and then deleted
it it was this picture of venom biting
spider-man basically cutting him in half
now this picture was very legitimate it
is confirmed that he did in fact post it
and then delete it and Tom Hardy has
been known to do this with other photos
and relations to venom two not many
people thought too much about it after
all the first photo that he posted had a
caption of just kidding however just
yesterday after the release of the venom
2 teaser he posted it again and plenty
of people captured this one as well
including myself I physically saw it on
his Instagram so what is Tom Hardy
teasing with this photo of venom
chomping spider-man in half so is Tom
Hardy actually teasing something here
well for starters he posted this
immediately after he posted the teaser
for venom 2 and then deleted it so it
seems to be connected to venom 2 on the
surface and then we have the Morbius
trailer Morbius is going to be taking
place in the same universe that venom
existent and we already know that
Morbius is kind of going to tie into the
MCU he'll tie into the MCU but only in
relation
to spiderman characters hence why we saw
vulture in the trailer so Morbius is
connected to venom but Morbius is also
connected to spider-man so it's safe to
assume that the venom averse that we
have going on right now with Sony is
also going to be connecting to the MCU
spider-verse
as well and then you have the fact that
Sony actually wanted Tom Holland to
appear as spider-man in the very first
venom film however Marvel said no they
didn't want people to confuse the Sony
verse with the MCU but after the whole
spider-man in the MCU Sony Disney Marvel
deal it looks like Sony and Disney have
struck up a new arrangement and they've
sort of created their own little
universe a universe that doesn't exactly
take place in the MCU but the MCU
spider-man can go into the Sony verse
and if they wanted Tom Hollands
spider-man for venom 1 they definitely
want him for venom 2 and it seems like
that just may be happening because Tom
Hardy has teased this now twice now it
may not mean anything but there
certainly is a precedence for it and we
know that all of the fans are dying to
see venom and spider-man together and
Tom Hardy knows that as well so for him
to tease that and not mean anything by
it is a pretty cruel joke but let me
know what you think do you think Tom
Hardy is teasing the fact that
spider-man could be in venom 2 or do you
think he's just messing around let me
know what you think in the comments down
below also don't forget to give this
video a like and subscribe with
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on all things relating to
venom a to look out for my giveaway
video tonight and as always thank you
all so much for watching
wolf off